les Français ne peuvent plus de cette
immigration massive qui change le visage
de notre pays et un vecteur d'insécurité
les Français ne veulent plus la financer
ils en ont pensé de voir des demandeurs
d'asile ou même des étrangers sous
occupé F remplir les pages des journaux
non pas pour des choses positives mais
pour des meurtres et des agressions
quotidiennes qu'attendez-vous pour agir
nous avons nous un projet déjà prêt clé
en main celui de Marine Le Pen nous vous
donnons monsieur le ministre nous vous
donnons notre accord pour le
copier-coller vous pourriez ainsi vous
attaquer aux droits du sol et à la
délinquance en expulsant les délinquants
étrangers réformez l'ame réformer le
droit d'asile bref vous pourriez avec le
projet de Marine Le Pen répondre aux
attentes légitimes des Français et
tourner la page du manque de courage
politique votre question d'actualité
avons-nous été demandé avant que vous
vous rendiez compte de l'énorme de
l'innommable et de l'insupportable de
vos réactions le jour de ces événements
absolument désastreux d'Annecy
pour lequel je veux avoir aujourd'hui
quelques mots
d'ailleurs les victimes ne vous
intéressent pas vous n'avez pas un mot
pour les enfants ce n'est pas un mot
pour les parents pendant cette question
d'actualité
si finalement l'histoire ne se déroule
pas comme l'imagine Madame Le Pen et
tout le rassemblement national et je
peux vous dire que c'est le dégoût qui
nous inspire quand vous parlez de ce
sujet et je vous ferai remarquer que
Madame Le Pen a déjà été jugé sur son
programme par deux fois elle a été battu
avec ce présidentiel
je vais vous faire remarquer depuis que
50 ans que le Front national pour de
l'adversité le refus de l'altérité et la
haine à chaque fois les Français lui
disent non et c'est un grand peuple que
le peuple français